okay so the batman gives us a showdown  for the ages in which the dark knight  faces off against the riddler in a  battle that spans gotham batman  eventually manages to capture the  character towards the end of the film  after he snipes falcone from his  apartment window however he actually  could have caught him sooner had he paid  attention to the photos of the mayor  these were clearly taken from a high  vantage point overlooking the iceberg  lounge which we later find out is edward  nashton's home we even get a wide shot  of the club at one point and in the top  corner we can see nashton looking out of  his window taking photos of the lounge  had batman figured out whereabouts the  photos were taken he could have caught  nash in sooner and the movie would have  been 10 minutes long which yeah not as  fun as what we got yeah sorry for  ruining your day there